y'as sru c'est bien dans ce nouveau coup
de fil le temps c'est un truc qu'on
subit tous
on sait tous que c'est pourtant je
saurais pas vous l'expliquer là comme ça
en deux mots la preuve c'est que j'ai
dis un truc c'est ce que c'est mais posé
des mots dessus c'est une autre paire de
manches
c'était en tout cas la conviction d'un
vieil homme d'église a parlé du temps 2
saint-augustin augustin d'hippone des
saint-augustin est un philosophe né en
354 est mort en 430 en algérie
saint-augustin a suivi une trajectoire
plutôt atypique il reçoit une éducation
chrétienne très forte et du coup il a un
peu saoulé par toute cette religion qui
la délaisse à la fin de ses études et
par enseigner dans des écoles de
rhétorique à carthage puis rome et milan
durant cette période il se marie devient
père d'un fils mais connaît également
une vie de débauche et de tentations en
italie entre les théâtres les poètes et
les philosophes et là elle rencontre un
homme qui va changer sa vie
saint-ambroise saint-ambroise c'est un
grand théoricien qui va beaucoup
influencé saint-augustin du coup ils
décident de se tourner à nouveau vers le
christianisme et lors d'une promenade
dans un jardin de milan boum
révélations il entend une voix qu'ils
considèrent comme celle de dieu donne je
t'aime beaucoup jama mais moi d'y
répondre non non non je crois pas moi il
ne parle quand même vachement suivants -
quand je parle il me répond ok google
montre moi des photos de glaçage
décapite ils quittent l'enseignement
commence à écrire des essais
philosophiques par vivre dans un
monastère puis devient prêtre et se
donne pour but de faire une synthèse du
platonisme et du christianisme en
tentant de démontrer que les deux
pensées étaient complémentaires
en gros faire cohabiter religions et
philosophies croyances et raison hélas
plutôt réussi son coup puisqu'il a été
canonisé et là un épisode du coup de fil
dédiés jeu mais près de quel est le plus
stylé
il a fait trois grandes oeuvres
confession la trinité et la cité de dieu
et dans le libre 11 de confession oui il
écrivait beaucoup dans le livre once de
confession il dit qu'est-ce que donc le
temps six personnes me le demande je le
sais mais si on me le demande que je
veuille l'expliquer je ne sais plus et
c'est vrai sans y réfléchir on utilise
des marques temporel ou des verbes
conjugués
quand on parle ce qu'indiquent des
notions de temps et nous permet de les
comprendre alors
a beaucoup de mal à expliquer ce qu'est
le temps une fois qu'on nous le demande
jusque-là aristote et d'autres
philosophes avait défini le temps comme
un mouvement que l'on mesure comme ça
c'est une vision plutôt classiques qui
représentent le passé le présent et le
futur sur une droite infinie le présent
est en plein milieu avec le passé ce qui
a été et le futur ce qui n'est pas
encore on peut à partir de la classe et
tous les mouvements qui se passe se
passeront où se sont passées mais
saint-augustin va s'opposer à cette
vision en expliquant que le temps et
l'espace doivent être dissociée car
l'espace est mêlé observable
quantifiable mais que le temps n'est pas
car c'est un pur passage jamais figé
donc l'être du temps c'est de tendre au
nom m et c'est la même chose pour le
passé le futur et le présent le passé ne
peut pas être puisqu'il n'est plus tout
comme le futur parce qu'il n'est pas
encore et le présent quant à lui soit il
devient automatiquement du passé soi et
devient éternité et donc c'est plus du
présent la caractéristique première du
temps c'est qu'il passe si le temps et
c'est parce qu'il tend à ne pas être sur
sa nouvelle compilation saint-augustin
reprend les plus grands classiques de la
chanson française au présent du présent
avec francis cabrel ou mets toi à prix
sûreté poignet je t'aime je t'aime mais
je t'aime avec claude françois
ja
à temps j'attends d'en temps si le auro
habite christophe et je crie je crie ali
pour qu'elle revient et je pleure je
pleure
david hallyday tu ne me laisse pas le
temps de te dire tout ce que je t'aime
et en bonus une chanson internationale
oui oh oui oh what you go pour
saint-augustin le temps n'existe donc
pas par lui-même mais uniquement dans
l'esprit de chacun c'est comme il dit
une extension de l'esprit nous avons
tous dans notre esprit une notion du
temps singulière qui peut se diviser
également en trois temps mais pas passés
présents et futurs
non mais c'est trois présents le présent
du passé le présent du présent et le
présent du futur comme on vient de voir
le passé le futur en tant que telle ne
peuvent pas être mais la sensation qu'on
a du temps passé est bien réelle c'est
ça le présent du passé
la notion du passé en un moment présent
ce que saint-augustin appelle la mémoire
et c'est pareil pour le futur le présent
du futur c'est notre perception du temps
à venir un moment présent il va appeler
ça la tente et enfin le présent du
présent on peut difficilement être plus
dans le présent qu'au présent
saint-augustin va qualifier ça de vision
on peut mettre toutes ces informations
dans un tableau avec présent du passé
présent du présent présent du futur
mémoire vision et attentes
nous on est dans le présent et on est
sans cesse en activité entre la mémoire
et la tente si vous méditer par exemple
vous avez dû vous en rendre compte
comme son attrait pour la religion le
prouve saint-augustin était quelqu'un de
plutôt spirituel et son étude du temps
ça se résume pas élucidé un problème
pratique ce qu'il kiffe lui c'est la
conception psychologique qu'on peut
avoir le rapport personnel de chacun
autant mais aussi son importance dans
notre relation avec dieu car le temps
fait partie des éléments qui vont
différencier dieu le créateur de ce
qu'ils créent les créatures
ça dérange ces jeunes athlètes non non
la bête on papote maquette au sérieux
les 30.2 regard rien wayne revient
lantoine victoire sur des buts tant de
temps que ça sans me disant mais le
boulet quoi je suis désolé c'est pour
moi la notion de temps ça n'existerait
pas tout ça tout ça quoi je suis désolé
je laisse le barça ce tu es quand on
parle de créatures ici c'est pas
seulement nous les êtres vivants mais
c'est aussi la matière l'espace le temps
tout ce qui fait notre univers du coup
lui il s'en fout un peu des gens qui se
moquent de dieu quand il se demande pas
pourquoi il a mis des siècles pour créer
tout ce qui nous entoure
encore une fois tout est une question de
temps le temps c'est une créature de
dieu une invention dieu lui vit hors
dehors de tout ça dans l'éternité
là où le temps et l'espace n'existe pas
ne peut pas y avoir d'avant d'après de
plus tôt ou plus tard c'est donc
l'expérience du temps entre autres qui
va différencier dieu de ses créatures
n'hésitez pas à profiter du présent du
présent qui sera déjà le présent du
passé pour passer le coup de fil à un
ami
et vous abonner à la chaîne a notamment
en cliquant sur la cloche pour être sûr
de ne rater aucune des prochaines vidéos
le concept qu'on vient de voir et se
posent pas mal à la conception du temps
chez parménide si vous avez raté ce coup
de fil là c'était le tout dernier
je vous mets le lien en fin de vidéo et
dans l'inscription j'espère en tout cas
que cette vidéo vous aura plu vous
envoie du love et de la pisse rial
[Musique]
avec adam